africa is from 7
jul my freight trains naples shoah
the last pencil that a point
arrived in 2
no if john kennedy sells water giwa
da moby the population up
in the father but today you appear to me travail the
pupa  the questions speak little about it to
find a puma and more partners
are born the wine of Italy together mine
from trani
the me and you theme of angel the thread and jerry
book a cube of people who are
we wanted la7
just a cream g
cit  ramble wrote it for pa also that
on the web from blue as types specola weight
in whites is known
messina is a city that has always lived
with the sea
we are a seaside city
my name is giuseppe pinci I am a
divemaster
[Music]
migrant boys from  africa come
here with many difficulties and therefore live
the sea as an enemy
three years ago the principal of the
nautical institute together with the teachers proposed me to
train the boys they
have inside the school who
are migrants how to swim how to have an
activity  ity underwater
[Music]
ok let's look you breathe
we have mine very good
the first step we have and first
aid precisely because it can be
easier for them then to deal
with the problems that they could
have coming practically in the water
other uses yes if the harm  mount the home
page the samp here is the person person
a breath
the first time we take them in the
water we do not know what their
reaction will be is something that we know is
difficult because when gold enters the
water they have to overcome their fears
[  Music]
simon scores with poland in dance pomo
oro blu because kendall amia and was in
any case the suv and in any case from lamberto
does thin in the usa he will teach how the
person to person the whites once
this is overcome and therefore understanding
what their difficulties can be
then in the water an introductory lesson
to scuba divers explaining why they
can learn to love and experience the
sea,
starting first of all from the
respect for the sea
[Music]
this is a statement because
dad
[Music]
the best thing about diving is not
so much seeing a smile but seeing the
light in a person's eyes
is not our victory but their
victory
[  Music]
wraps peppe like luigi zampa of the
motogp riders but but there gfs travail more
than a little more sauvé he saw the basics of a
day even more than me
[Music]